[Musique]
dans les milliers de lettres que nous
recevons il y a toujours un mot pour
mabrook une bise une caresse mabrook
nous dites-vous est un peu notre chien
et nous voulons avoir le plus souvent
possible de ces nouvelles alors pour
vous les caméras de 30 millions d'amis
ont suivi mabrook pendant une journée de
détente une journée loin des moquettes
des studios des régies il nous invite
aujourd'hui à le suivre dans une de ses
activités favorites de
weekend il ne s'agit pas en effet de ces
flaneries inutiles pas traînant et
regards vague même pendant ses loisirs
mabrook aime
s'instruire depuis qu'il suit la saga du
cheval dans 30 millions d'amis il est
très attiré par ce grand quadrupède il a
donc décidé de visiter les écuries et le
manège qui se trouve près de chez
lui
un qu'est-ce qui se passe
[Musique]
ici voil le copain
de est légèr intimidé mais comme tout
berger allemand qui respecte il ne lâche
pas son matre d'un
SAB avec S chevx on sait
jamais punchy c'est le chien de l'écurie
un habitué du milieu connaît tous les
trucs de l'équitation un chien à
suivrey qu'est-ce qu'on va faire on
obser
[Musique]
comme il faut toujours commencer par se
détendre on entame d'abord une bonne
bagarre attention on est copain mais on
fait pas de
cadeau rassurez-vous ma connaî sa force
rappelez-vous que la pression de ces CR
est de 600 kg au CM
car
heureusement punchy n'en fait pas les
frais car en parfait adepte des Ares
Marti mabrou retient ses
[Musique]
coups
un petit tour dans les boxes histoire de
prendre
[Musique]
contact allons-y bon ils nont pas l'air
vraiment
marrant enfin peut-être qu'il faut les
connaître à la longue la communication
va peut-être
s'établir hein
je vois venir avec vos gross
sabot en attendant mieux vous retourner
jouer à judo on appelle ça une
immobilisation
ah c'est bon de s'amuser un peu tiens
voilà les cavaliers les chevaux sa
sautent c'est connu mais les bergers
allemands aussi mabrook doit être fidèle
à sa réputation lui qui chaque semaine
bondit à travers l'écran quelques
séances d'entraînement et plus un seul
obstacle ne devrait résister à la
prodigieuse détente musculaire de notre
mascotte le défi est lancé très bientôt
vous verrez mabrook dans la grande
course qu'il opposera un fringant étalon
un rendez-vous à ne pas
manquer